building something that looks great in
the visual layer data is the easy part
you also need to consider different
screens and orientations as you begin to
layout your UI there's a temptation to
build a pixel perfect for the device you
happen to be using at the time this is
reinforced by the fact that your apps
window doesn't generally change size
while it's running so you can't just
grab the lower right corner and grow and
shrink your app to see how it behaves
but if you've ever developed for the web
or desktop you know this static approach
is a bad idea when Android first
launched hvga 480 by 320 resolution
screens were standard as we began
exploring how to build engaging user
experiences on those devices we could
use absolute layouts to define the exact
location of each screen element but
within a year the first WVGA Android
phones were released and now Android
runs on everything from phones to
phablets tablets TVs and wearables with
any screen size resolution and aspect
ratio you can imagine so just like
desktop or web where you might use
panels or CSS your Android UI needs to
scale based on the screen it's running
within which is why absolute layout was
deprecated in favor of layouts like
linear layout relative layout and grid
layout that can dynamically resize and
adapt to any screen following the
principles of responsive design